[Music]
in search for happiness news submitted
by the ghost of Tiff's blue hair both of
y'all went back to natural yeah and I
just got worse waiting Oh
your eyebrows blue I mean I'm gonna go
back to blue bow I'm just waiting for my
hair to go along you think of giving any
other colors I got a new color for you
what magenta oh that's kind of like
parts of Gina's hair like in there
somewhere
yeah and then you can be a bowl of Red
Robin
ah no I'll be angry all the time oh yeah
Sonny finds that being popular in high
school may not actually lead to
happiness that's so true cuz you Pete
then and then you don't know how to
handle the rest of your life so many
girls that were like so [ __ ] hot in
like high school and I look back at
their Facebook and it's like they got
pregnant in life and then like not that
pregnant makes you ugly or old or
anything like that because TIFF
is like yeah not that Bob just say like
all those girls like what what ended up
happening is like you just live life too
fast
yeah and they get old really fast there
was this one girl that used to pick on
me in seventh grade it was science class
she's really pretty she's like half
asian half white girl and she was one of
those super popular girls she was like
so Gina what do you want to be when you
grow up and me my ugly ass braces
headgear like you had headgear what the
[ __ ]
during the day but like at night its
sleep I had to wear like head gear house
[ __ ] girls is awesome awesome and I
was like I want to be a model and she
got all her friends in class laugh at me
and I'm like you're never gonna be a
model and then what is she doing she's a
mechanic and then you come out she used
to pull my hair and like make fun of me
and then when I was at Jenny Jones when
I was around like 20 20 years old and I
was modeling like she she found me on
Facebook she's like oh my god hey
I want to be a model too oh my god give
me some advice but she got huge is she
to be like the hood rat San Jose girls
you know so like big they could never
get their eyebrows right yeah yeah why
they just like ah [ __ ] it and then they
go like always looking like confusing
[ __ ] or surprise like rise yeah so this
study they're saying that you're in high
school and you seek popularity or you
seek acceptance from your peers those
teenagers they grow up to not have long
term happiness because they're not able
to form relationships with like
meaningful relationships with people
when they're in high school so then they
can't do that once they're out of high
school so what matters most is teens
that have close friendships are evil
they're able to grow up and be more
emotionally intelligent as adults don't
most people have had a seeking
acceptance from their peers though but I
think with this article sitting is when
you seek popularity specifically yeah we
do want to be accepted in high school
right but at least for myself I never
want I I would have liked to have been
popular but it was never something I was
pushing for you know like I just wanted
to be accepted by just so it's like
being accepted by people that don't
really matter if you're close friends
except you that's all that matters one
to be over quality yeah one I don't
remember how to be popular
I just knew like I was a lot you were
yeah I just didn't give a [ __ ] about the
people in school I never hung out with I
still only have like one high school
friend that I still talk to you too but
like I just I always had the older kids
I went clubbing but never give a [ __ ]
about the kids in school boria's like in
high school I went through a lot of
phases yeah so I don't really know yeah
I was a stoner depends I was a goth kid
I was like a weird goth kid oh we would
probably be friends yeah I went through
phases to like I went through it oh
that's right yeah when Newt or like
through the we would have been friends I
really wish I would have met you during
Tortola years I was never like fully in
I was like
lip liner lip liner I'd yeah yeah I
tried you had the eyebrowns
I Brown rounds no I never shaved my
eyebrows or anything but you always like
happy were you always a week not not
mommy maybe well one of the main high
school balls more like really quiet and
I won't have been friends with yeah
don't worry dark
have you seen senior my senior
volleyball yeah all the athletes yeah
yeah people thought I was Filipino are
like Cambodian damn dark Oh like how the
hell did this happen like you went from
stop salt Asian to North like you guys
dressed like Ray bruised at all I had
the big raver pants but they were gone
like chains and zippers I I changed a
little bit too yeah cuz it also depends
on the area you're from so like where I
grew up
thugs were a little bit more like the
gqueues solid badass Paulo that you like
barely tuck in like this part then the
rest of it like pour it out yeah and
then you were like a 90s R&B group yeah
yeah so I started off like well I wanted
to seek acceptance with with other gangs
I didn't want to look like a [ __ ] so I
would always get in fights like I got
would never question it right and then I
would you and I've got into like this
pothead musician phase where all we did
was just blaze and just play drums and
then like jam out like crazy then I got
into like a crazy rate of her face so I
think that depending on like the stage I
was in life the wardrobe change and my
interests also change and how I looked
and how I acted and who I cared accepted
me also change when I got into like the
raving stuff I only cared if other
ravers accepted me cuz I don't no one
else understood what Pleroma
I remember like being interested in how
other groups and people thought all the
time so I would just go and start
joining good huh Bernie yeah I would
just come visit like and I'll play
basketball with them and I'm like oh
what are these guys doing these nerds
are playing magic card you just explore
yeah and I was like what is this I want
to learn and then like oh you guys ditch
and get stoned let's go and then like
I'll jump the fence of all goes smoke
weed at the friend's house yeah you have
like different groups of friends that
you
yeah under that - during lunch time I
would go throughout the quad and be like
oh let me see what the preppy kids are
doing other dancers are doing I feel
like my school is just so there's this
one I went to three different high
schools one of them during lunch people
would hang out in different groups right
so there was literally they call it -
over here's Asia over here's Africa BAM
land is over here and like many girls
yeah but it was really weird like when I
first came there they're like okay so
you hanging out this we were over here
in Asia only what was this this was up
in NorCal it was a orange grove was it
up big high school yes my first high
school was hella racially segregated hmm
all the black people on one side
Mexicans Asians and then like they would
always be race race riots like fightin
stuff my first high school everyone was
all chilled together like that school
was [ __ ] dope a slope at school and
then and then I went to Orange Grove
where it's like [ __ ] different
countries and [ __ ] one time I saw these
girls fight and they ripped off one of
her weaves it's awesome I love that I
love watching I love seeing waves on the
floor its allure I thought girl fights
were all like crazier than guy fight
yeah there's always like clothes that
rip off yeah yeah and hair well now that
we have social media of you guys I tried
I've been curious and see who was
popular back in the day and then see
them now I stopped them you know I'm
friends with a lot of everyone like a
lot of people on Facebook that were my
high school people I haven't done that
actually maybe I should do it and it's
pretty cool cuz they're like oh my god
you're so famous now I'm like not really
but haha like the popular girls a
message to me like oh my god you know
like don't [ __ ] talk to me [ __ ]
I did have an old friend randomly call
me this is like two years ago and I
still lived it on hammer I got this
random phone call and I'm like what the
hell why is he calling me cuz this is
like back in when I was in high school
in Cerritos he goes hey just won't let
you know I have a couple dispensaries
now I would love to do like a brand deal
promotion with you and I'm like I know I
see I've seen some kids that were
popular in my high school and then I see
them doing the exact same thing they
were doing when you're in high school
which was trying to make it in like the
rap game and they're doing the exact
same kind of music videos like
nothing six like booty-shaking and girls
from high school like they've all gained
weight but they're still trying to do
the same thing I'm like oh man no longer
it has anyone from your guys's high
school gone on to do something real cool
like I have a friend right now as a
professional Joe Fraser I met and like
it's so cool like we were united because
I became his umbrella girl and that's
how we reunited what Joe did with Tim
Tim yeah I went to junior high with Tim
Tim Duncan he told me that and then in
high school oh yeah we know someone that
he's behind the scenes kind of mm-hmm
yeah he managed couple of youtubers cool
I know there's probably more but most of
them ain't doing [ __ ] no I do know
people that I met in high school though
that went off to doing good stuff like
to musicians Tokyo Austin no such thing
shot us to you guys yeah I knew her
before she did music I've always loved
that name that's a guy right he went to
school with you yeah yeah
two of the dudes that I know that used
to bein their pastors now oh that's
interesting I had then to God like with
the oh that was calling talk to sex men
Oh sexy sax man ezio oh yeah my other
friend
I was classmates with this sister and
then he became like a pre he's like a
up-and-coming Instagram photographer for
a lot of hot models Oh Duncan you
probably know him
it has nothing do the donuts I'm not
just any more I see you guys in high
school I don't worry about being popular
just worry about you and building your
skill set you still say you wanna be hey
what's up guys thanks for watching we
are going to regularly start posting
content on the JK films Instagram so
make sure you follow us there our last
video click over here